je suis mitigé en fait sur sur la
question on va dire que d'un côté sam
abécédaire par ailleurs on va être
honnête hier j'ai pas du tout regardé
l'émission rémois julien d'initiés pas
regardé j'ai même pas regarder
que ça
c'est dit oui je suis désolé je connais
pas du tout les noms des chroniqueurs du
tu connais
que j'étais magnifique je vous le redis
reset magnifique ses rimes mais alors
elle joue bien fait mais bien le 50 m je
veux dire encore giulia ali sur le avec
filtre ali exceptionally exceptionnelle
sur les photos aller où on bloque sur le
site hier à la télé allez voilà un et
l'a fait en vrai et bien une fille
magnifique ah oui je vous lis giuly en
fait aimer les ombres est partout non
non vous êtes magnifique doublé serait
très belle giulia donc c'est vrai qu'il
ya eu l'émission on a vu sur les réseaux
il ya plein de gens qui ont dit que vous
aviez mis des filtres et que voilà il
est est ce que vous avez été choqué par
la tonalité des messages alors j'ai
regardé au début parce que on a un gros
poids de sap avec les personnes qui ont
fait l'émission avec moi donc un groupe
on rigole bien et ses hommes envoyer
l'image et au travail ont déjà j'ai une
image ces faits n'ont laissé tomber ça
va pas être possible ensuite je me suis
quand même renseigné je regarde un peu
sur m6 etc et là je tombe des nues parce
qu'on est déjà je vois le début de
l'extrait jeu mais pas le son clairement
je suis pas allé jusqu'à la fin de
l'extrait je ne savais pas que mon image
allait être entre kim et ernie comme ça
après je peux reconnaître que la
différence entre les photos qui sont
montrés à gauche et la photo qui est
montré qu'il monterait à droite c'est
vrai que c'est par semblant plus tôt
maintenant est-ce que ça m'a vraiment
touché non parce qu'en fait je me
reconnais pas dans la personne qui à
gauche
sans me vanter je reconnais clairement
plus dans la personne à la droite plutôt
cool hein ouais ouais même si cette
photo elle date de 2018 je me reconnais
clairement plus ont été tournées quand
ça myard mois d'accord mais depuis
depuis le tournage j'ai pris trois kilos
ah oui de quoi vous dire à quel point je
me suis pas reconnu en fait et ce qui
m'a le plus choqué c'est la réaction de
mon entourage qui m'a dit mais en fait
je te reconnais pas je t'ai reconnue
grâce à des tatouages été reconnu grâce
à tes yeux mais messi non aux visions et
m'ont pas reconnu et moi même je me suis
pas reconnu c'est ça qui m'a valu ma
plus de blessés c'est que dans les
images prouvent super prix j'ai bon moi
je trouve que le festival est la
tonalité des messages c'est proprement
honteux mais j'ai une question à vous
poser vous êtes magnifique au naturel et
vous avait désarçonné c'est vrai je me
mets à sa place vous avait désarçonné
votre prétendant pierre parce que
lui-même quand il vous a vu bon il a eu
une réflexion et olala c'est chaud il a
pas que c'est pas beau mais il n'a pas
compris pourquoi est ce que vous avez
fait ces photos filtré qui ne vous
ressemble pas du tout et qui ont tout
gâché selon moi peut-être que ça rien
gâcher et peut-être que je sais plus qui
a dit ça mais je me suis arrêté au
moment où on l'a dit dès que j ai pas
mis de filtre et cetera ou que les
photos étaient pas comme ça même si des
photos qui datent après c'est normal
quand on crache sur quelqu'un entre
guillemets on remonte le fil à phoenix
le style des photos un état grave
peut-être qu'ils seraient jamais venus
aussi après c'est moi qui l'ait dit
c'est moi
qui l'ait dit le fait voilà je vous le
dis oui et tout le monde le fait gilles
domaine des fautes bédéphiles truc comme
ça sur un stade louis-ii d'un filtre
même là moi j'ai trouvé que tout le
monde avait été traînée en exil âgé
truqués téléspectateurs étaient violents
sur twitter j'ai truc son prétendant été
violent pardon mais quand une fille vous
avez un deck dit oh [ __ ] c'est chaud
c'est extrêmement vue à marseille son
talent voilà regardez
là ça va halo reach
ça fait bizarre de voir un peu ça fait
bizarre je m'étais imaginé julia weston
kardashian donc c'est vrai que je me
sois un peu gêné c'est un peu de larmes
ac c'est par la fille des photos qui me
plaît et si je te plaît aussi tout est
parfait
voilà voilà
alors ça vous fait que c'est la première
fois que je vois les images en fait
c'est pour ça que ça me savais vraiment
très bien vous pouvez commencer c'est
drôle moi je trouve aussi ces massacres
ont mis
alors à la fin donc il s'installa par
match et entre vous deux bah voir
l'extrait puisque vous allez découvrir
que vous regardez là la fin parce que
vraiment dit tu me plais de ouf j'ai
envie de faire ma vie avec toi ça serait
mentir et j'ai pas envie de mentir tout
simplement je pense que voilà on a un
bon feeling on s'entend bien ouais c'est
ça on se plaît on s'entend bien voilà
donc du coup du coup
[Musique]
il a sans surprise d'être en cours
alors je pense que avec julia il ya une
belle amitié avant tout on est vraiment
des confidents il ça va très bien comme
ça c'est resté pas tout bas non d'accord
non mais c'est assez comique parce que
c'est pas exactement ce qu'on a dit
après c'était des gens se feront leur a
dit mais de base hors étaient censés
repartir en relation libre sauf qu'il ya
beaucoup de choses qui ont pas été
passée apparemment dans les experts
d'accord pendant l'émission maintenant
les gens se font un propre avis et dans
tous les cas carrément ça n'a pas marché
donc la finalité reste la même et les
sonos les gens fabuler faire un peut
inventer des choses et c'est très bien
et ça me convient parfaitement et
d'ailleurs c'est grâce à ces personnes
là que je suis là donc j'aimerais bien
les remercie aujourd'hui on est assez
twitter mais remercié aussi également
ceux qui m'ont soutenu ça vous ça vous a
blessé quand même les choses que vous
avez lu ça m'a pas blessée parce que
comme je vous ai dit je me suis pas
reconnu en fait ouais je me suis
clairement pas reconnu et osent
critiquer quelqu'un qui était pas ou pas
bon critiquer quelqu'un qui était pressé
témoin mais c'est pas exactement mois
déjà les restaurants mais c'est vrai
mais déjà les personnes qui ne va pas
faire la différence entre la télé et ce
qu'ils disent en réalité elle et elle
est à limoges ça y est dégueulasse que
j'ai quand même vu baleineau machin tu
ressembles à un travesti et c'est à
gauche et ses entraves
d'ailleurs cette personne est venu
s'excuser quand je dis que ça a remarqué
des traits construction
ouais c'est c'est moi mais la télé ça
reste la télé sur on est d'accord que la
réalité enfin vous voyez en face c'est
tout ce qu'elle voyait quand même que je
suis un peu mieux et plus vite mais je
vous le confirme
confirme
je vous le confirme je connais un petit
peu la gente féminine j'ai offert à
tous vous le confirme et j'en conviens
pas s'il ya beaucoup de gens qui me
disent je suis beaucoup mieux entré les
gens ne voient pas mais j'ai
l'impression que la production elle est
dure avec vous parce que là je pense que
le dés qu'il a duré plus de longues
minutes voire plusieurs heures ils vous
font clairement passé pour l'art
n'accélérant que vous êtes une arnaque
vous êtes mieux réagi siècle voilà
l'arnaqué du siècle met en bio rasta et
je pense qu'ils mettent tous en scène
parce qu'ils veulent faire une émission
agréable à regarder ce qui est le cas
mais il oublie que ça peut être très
violent et qu'elles presque un million
de personnes qui regardent et je pense
que vous êtes fait défoncer sur les
réseaux et c'est très injuste est ce que
vous avez le sentiment
truqué déformer la réalité ouais
clairement oui après c'est le sait c'est
le jeu quand on fait de la télé là
j'aurais dû fin j'étais un peu noyé sur
le coup parce que pour moi c'était une
mission qui est passé à 23 heures
c'était une émission pour s'amuser on
devait passer vingt minutes à tout
casser à l'écran et je pensais pas que
tout ce que j'aurais pu dire et des
choses que j'ai pu dire aussi entre
guillemets en confidence à la personne
qui m'a interviewé ça aurait pu être à
ce point pour moi à mes yeux déformés et
là j'ose le dire devant vous parce que
je les dis aussi à la productrice de
l'émission et j'ai été transparente avec
elle je lui ai dit vous m'avez
clairement créé des complexes que je
n'avais pas d'accord mais quand même
ouais ben oui ça m'a créé des comptes
est que je n'avais pas j'ai vu des
commentaires qui est si vrai je me suis
jamais posé la question de pourquoi là
j'ai des petits yeux alors que sans les
photos instagram gdgt grands yeux même
si avec la fatigue et c'est pourquoi
j'ai trois bourrelets alors que même
quand on est gros n'a qu'un seul truc
enfin ça m'a vraiment créer des
complexes que je n'avais pas weekly moi
j'ai quand même l'impression que comme
beaucoup de jeunes femmes et et moi
aussi j'en fais partie je pense que si
justement tu en as des complexes parce
que si on met autant de filtre sur les
réseaux c'est pour cacher nos complexes
ça veut dire que quand on a un nez comme
ça et qu'on le met comme ça quand on
n'aime pas et qu'on l'avait comme ça
enfin je veux dire il faut le dire quand
même mais peut-être que justement à
cause de vous et les gens qui insultent
sur les réseaux et on se fait harceler
tous les jours et bah ouais au final on
a mis deux pandas envie de mettre des
filtres et je pense que ce discours là
il pourrait être plus juste parce que tu
vois ce garçon quand il a dit oh [ __ ]
bas au final il a été choqué parce que
ouais est ce que t'as pas l'impression
d'avoir arnaqué mais pas dans le mauvais
sens dans le sens où c'était pas ton
image son image année là elle est très
belle et malheureusement à cause des
réseaux et ben en fait on se crée une
image qui n'est pas la bonne tout a été
fait pour que en balanche arnaque wade
après chacun cherche quoi moi déjà je
dirais pas pourquoi il a dit au cul
temps après c'est sa regarder m6 et
c'est pourquoi ce nom ça regarder m6
m'annoncer c'est une très bonne qualité
les doigts pages très bonne remarque
très bonne question que vous que vous
avez trouvé parce que justement grâce il
ya du positif
c'est chaud c'est cyril on m'a déjà pas
respectées c'est de me respecter bonnes
raisons
monsieur déplacer je vais changer après
le travail j'aime respecter un minimum
par le lay parle de ton ami en fin de
vie parce que tu as c'est pas drôle
assez pour ce prix-là dire [ __ ] j'ai
dit dans la lettre ses consignes au xv
tu sais faire
n'importe quoi je sers moi le sexe
fait parler d'elle c est ce qu on est là
pour parler terme est ce qu on est là
pour parler de moi bien c'est moitié
moins c'est pas bien non mais oui mes
blagues et
rigole avec mon chéri et moi ça y est
nous y
serions des potes aussi enfin giuly à ce
que tu as trouvé l'amour là mais du coup
je voulais juste répond d'abord à kelis
et sa non pas si c'est ça vous dérange
pas parce que justement c'est une très
bonne remarque que j'avais pu et
j'aimerais revue et augmentée c'est que
justement tout ça le fait que les gens
se focalisent sur mon poids sur mon
visage sont la ressemblance entre les
poteaux ça m'a fait oublier mon plus
gros complexe et qui est visible moi je
les ai vus dans les extraits qui est
visible mais qui n'est pas que
apparemment tout le monde a trop tôt
vous pouvez le voir si je me lève vous
pouvez le voir c'est quoi voir
c'est quoi et qu'il a un ring rêve de po
s'est jetée victime d'un incendie donc
j'ai une greffe de peau tous là et
franchement j'ai vu aucun commentaire
qui en parlait donc se poser c'est mon
plus gros complexe de votre évier donc
voilà donc comment ça m'a aidé à assumer
ça et maintenant les roms tous âges et
plus